hey what's up everybody in case some of
you have been busy the last few days and
haven't been able to see my last few
videos I am doing a new giveaway which
you can find a link down in the
description to enter for your chance to
win the complete collection of the Game
of Thrones series on blu-ray so check
that out if you want to enter but now
let's get into today's video
[Music]
[Music]
this video will mostly be about House
Stark ancestral sword which was known as
ice which was originally forged in
ancient Valyria and has been passed down
through the generations it was actually
the first Valyrian steel sword we were
introduced to in the game of thrones
television series when we see Ned Stark
be had a deserter of the Nights Watch in
the very first episode the name of
Robert of the house Baratheon first of
his name don't look away
he knew Daniel from the first audible or
hated Lord of the Seven Kingdoms and
protector of the realm I Eddard the
House Stark Lord of Winterfell and
warden of the North sentence you to die
it was a massive sword that looked
almost too damn heavy to swing in fact
the sword was so big that it would
eventually be melted down and forged
into two new swords and unfortunately we
know how this part of the story ends Ned
Stark goes to King's Landing to be hand
of the king for Robert Baratheon and
while he's there he starts to uncover
the truth about Cersei and Robert's
children who are actually bastard
children fathered by Jaime Lannister
then Robert Baratheon eventually dies
and Ned starts to rebel against the
crown and is arrested and eventually
executed under the orders of the new
illegitimate King Joffrey but the ironic
thing about it is Sorel and Payne who
was the executioner actually used Ned
Stark's own sword to behead him so in it
bring me it
[Applause]
afterwards the sword was kept in King's
Landing basically as a trophy plus
Valyrian steel was very rare and was
something Tywin Lannister has wanted for
a very long time Tywin Lannister
eventually had ice melted down which I
must admit was a heartbreaking thing to
see the stark sword get melted down it
was just another reminder of the stark
family being ripped apart but there is
still hope that one day the stark sword
is returned to its original form and
returned to its rightful owners but
there is one interesting thing about ice
being melted down here and the
interesting thing is the man who did it
in the books the man who melts down ice
Andhra forces it into two new swords for
time a Lannister is none other than top
Oakmont and excuse me if I mispronounce
his name but Altamonte is someone you
have been introduced to before if your
show water's only top Oman has been
ginjuries mentor for quite some time now
and he learned his methods in car and
was one of the few armors in the show
who can work with Valyrian steel now in
the books there are a lot more people
who can reforge this deal but in the
television show Tywin Lannister says
there are only three people who know how
to reforge it which makes someone with
that knowledge to do so very important
in my opinion but as far as we know
there isn't anyone that knows how to
make Valyrian steel from scratch not
without the magic it requires during the
forging process but the man that Gendry
worked with day in and day out knew how
to reforge it and he knew how to do it
very well in Gendry working with this
man is not a coincidence and here is a
quote that Tahoe Montt
said himself - Ned Stark he said my work
is costly and I make no apologies for
that my lord you will not find
craftsmanship equal to mine anywhere in
the Seven Kingdoms I promise you visit
every forge and Kings Landing if you
like in compare for yourself any village
Smith's can hammer out a short of mail
but my work is art and who was the man
working with him busting his ass every
day which his mentor had complimented
him on several times he has been
learning this man's craft and is now
making art of his own
think about it George are Martin could
have fat ginjury work anywhere in the
story or he could have made him work for
any other Smith in King's Landing but he
didn't he works with the man who knows
how to reforge Valyrian steel for a
reason
and I'm going to say it again this is
not a coincidence now I briefly talked
about this in a previous video and
someone commented saying we have no
proof that ginjury ever worked with
Valyrian steel while he was a blacksmith
there which is true we don't have any
proof of that but that was for a reason
also they cannot reveal that just yet
that has to be saved for a later time
that way we think there is no way they
can ever make any more weapons then
that's when we're eventually going to
get a scene or chapter work entry says I
know how to make it I can reforge this
feel I was shown how my mentor showed me
how to do it and he could have showed
Gendry how to make it without ever
needing him to use actual Valyrian steel
all he really had to do was show him the
process so when a time comes to use
Valyrian steel he would know exactly how
to do it but regardless they already
gave us that clue that gendry's mentor
can reforged Valyrian steel which is
exactly why Gendry is working for that
man for this to come into play in the
future I guarantee it
this is a story where people have
desperately needed this precious metal
especially now that another war for the
dawn is upon us we're going to need
weapons to fight the white walkers now
more than ever in spoiler alert and
guess who is returning to the show just
in time before the wall falls I
guarantee this is one of the reasons
Gendry is coming back I think he's going
to be legitimized by Danny or John that
way he can continue the Baratheon name
in the war hammer you seen in the league
photos of Gendry on the beach I
guarantee you he made that hammer
himself he did not steal the hammer from
his father ginjuries a blacksmith that's
all he knows how to do when Davos helped
him escape from Dragonstone I guarantee
that's what Gendry went back to doing
and since Melisandre revealed who he was
I bet he made that hammer and honor of
his father and what was one other
important thing Melisandre said to
Gendry
you're more they can never be they're
just foot soldiers in the Great Wall you
will make Kings
she said you will make Kings rise and
fall
now when Melisandre said that she meant
that his blood would do this with her
magic but Melisandre has been wrong many
times before
she's always misinterpreting her own
visions I actually think this means
Gentry will make a weapon that makes a
king rise and fall possibly reforging
ice to be used in the new war for the
dawn that takes down the night King and
I know some of you are probably thinking
we don't need new Valyrian steel all
they got to do is use dragon glass let
me tell you something when the final
battle happens Jon Snow's going to fight
the night King one on one and it's not
going to be done with dragon class it's
going to be a sword fight and Jon's not
going to use Longclaw either he's going
to have a new sword long claw is not
going to be Lightbringer
it's going to be the most epic
one-on-one battle the show has ever seen
and when Jon takes on the knight King in
the final war he's going to have a brand
new sword and how [ __ ] awesome would
it be to see the stark sword put back to
its original form and it's the sword
that wins the biggest war I would
absolutely love that
but how will both swords end up back
with the Starks when Tywin gave Joffrey
one of the swords for his wedding gift
you can see the look on Santa's face
because she knows exactly where that
sword came from one of only two Valyrian
steel swords in the capital your grace
freshly forged in your honor
you see Songz's face
I bet Tyrion knows too especially after
Joffrey said it will be like cutting
Ned's head off again every time he uses
it which is a clear reminder that Ned's
head was cut off with his own sword and
half of that now belongs to Joffrey well
it did belong to Joffrey and thanks to
spoiler photos we know that Jaime
Lannister is now in possession of
widow's wail which does make me happy
because I now know that the sword isn't
buried in a pile of rubble or with
someone's dead body so the chances of
the Starks ending up with both swords
again as possible especially since bran
has Oathkeeper which is the other half
of Ned sword and since Brienne has sworn
to protect Sansa it's just a matter of
time before it's revealed where that
sword actually came from most people
think Jaime will forever be a piece of
[ __ ] but there's a better chance of him
doing the right thing with these swords
than Cersei would have ever done because
Jaime absolutely knows where this sword
came from
magnificent mmm looks fresh forged it is
no one's made a Valyrian steel swords is
the doom of Valyria there are three
living threat to know how to rework
Valyrian steel the finest of them was in
volantis came here to King's Landing at
my invitation where did you get this
much Valyrian steel from someone who no
longer had need of it so there are
plenty of people alive who know what
happened to Ned Stark's sword and now
that both swords are going to make an
appearance in season 7 the chances of
them ending up what the Starks again
have increased we just have to hope that
someone ends up making the right choice
and give them back to the rightful
owners and I do think that bran is going
to end up giving her sword to one of the
Starks and I think Tyrion could possibly
talk his brother Jaime into returning it
because once Tyrion is back inside the
stark circle during their alliance he's
going to be more eager to make things
right again or you never really know
what could happen Jaime and Brienne
could both end up dying which would
vacate ownership of both of their swords
I think there are a number of ways the
Starks can get them back and I'm very
confident that they will and I know
Gendry can reforge them to its original
form unless one of the Starks requested
to be different or to make it into
several weapons for the war but either
way I know the Starks are going to end
up having to steal again and that's all
that matters to me so comment below guys
and tell me what you think do you like
this idea do you want to see ice put
back together again do you have any
ideas of your own about how the Starks
can get both of these swords back to
make ice again or make something else
let me know because I'm curious what you
guys think about all this and as always
thanks for watching
I will see you guys down in the comment
section bye